[Applause]
welcome to the show stephen very nice to
have you back how
are you i'm fine how are you i'm good
i'm i'm good oh you're kids
i have one i have one if you've been
listening to the interview before you uh
i have one child nev a little girl yeah
she's great
eight months old what's that it's all
right
yeah i'll do that i'll tell her stephen
wright says hello
big fan big fan do you like kids
i like kids i don't have kids not uh you
know i don't have kids how you mean
i don't know you didn't ask me that but
i like kids
you sort of go into a whole strange area
you do enjoy kids i've seen you
i like them i've seen them you've seen
[Music]
they're not like when i was a kid though
when i was a kid
you know you'd go over and play with the
kids you'd build things you'd make
things you do
things kids today don't even talk to me
i wonder why
it shows how times have changed that's
changed
i understand you um i'm over here uh
you have more lights than you need yeah
i'm pretty pale i i need a lot of light
not a lot of light on this melon to show
up on television
sorry that frightened you clearly uh i
just said you just got back from
australia
yeah i went there to uh watch a movie
yeah
the good protectors in australia yeah
when i left like two days before i left
everything's back was there they turned
the clocks back an hour
right and then two days later i left and
i flew 18
hours to boston which is a 16-hour time
difference right and then two days later
we changed the
clocks ahead an hour and then the next
day somebody asked me if i knew what
time it is and i punched him in the head
just reared back in yeah yeah sorry for
that guy yeah time is tricky time is a
weird thing
it's a very strange thing that's
probably the most profound thing anyone
said on this show
in 11 years is time is a weird thing has
it been
has it been 11 years it's been uh it's
been 11 years
yeah see yeah you proved your point yeah
weird um
gonna get quiet again soon uh let me ask
you
you're always um you have the boston red
sox cap every time you come on the show
please please please let's vote later
there's a knob on your seat just turn it
to vote
do you know that booing was latin for
applause
so then the people applauding the red
sox were doing what they were plotting
oh you never studied latin no no i
didn't i blew it
wow you're quite good yeah but you're a
big red sox fan yes i've been how do you
feel
what was it since i was a child since
you were a child following the socks
you know not you know like in big very
emotional it's hard to earth sucks
brookline massachusetts yeah you can see
fenway park from my parents house wow
amazing yeah and you know
i hate to say this but you know p fenway
park
opened the same week that the titanic
sank
that's true i did sure i did know that
april uh april 14th 1912.
yep and like that knocked off the fenway
opening off the headlines
everything was a titanic and i hate to
say this because i'm such a fan but i
think subconsciously the red sox
are re-enacting the voyage of the tyson
[Applause]
incredible theory walk us through this
bill because you know it starts the
season starts and everyone's up
oh hey hawaii how's it going new uniform
new clothes everyone's getting on for
the season you know when everyone's on
and then
then the season takes off it leaves and
it goes slowly like the titanic
it's moving along and it's going and
then after a while they passed the
all-star game oh there's the all-star
game and then it keeps going and then
about
august late august september it's like
did you hear that noise off the left
[Laughter]
field
what was that noise off the lifter i
didn't hear anything i think i heard
something i think we should wake up the
manager
no he doesn't want to be disturbed and
then it's just sooner it's just
then it's over yeah yeah that's an
interesting theory thank you very much
depressing but you can always turn
around right
huh like maybe this is the year you
don't like it when i get close like
within i don't think matthew would like
that either people like
respect this person's face please stay
over there i'll stay over here
you're in a new movie coffee and i'm
doing this from my own zone the cone
zone uh
you're in a new movie uh coffee and
cigarettes
but this is the cone zone right here um
yeah tell me about
the movie coffee and cigarettes first of
all you don't smoke is that right
no i don't smoke and uh so during the
movie it's the movie's 11 segments of
people
meeting and having insane conversations
while
drinking coffee and smoking cigarettes
and it's like my segment is with
roberto benini and we have this insane
conversation but i don't smoke so i was
acting like i was smoking
and but i do drink coffee so i was
drinking the coffee
and at the same time i was acting like i
was drinking the coffee
so there's like a double thing happening
yeah that's pretty intense
i don't think our people would notice
that but for me i was doing like three
things at once
wow and uh it's good my part was film
though and it movie came out a month ago
my part was filmed in 1986. i heard this
this is true you filmed it in 1986.
because he was filming a little
a little bit at a time and i i had him
hold my section back for tax purposes
this is great thank you so much
he's him when i say him in this
regard i mean jim johnson whenever i say
him and
i don't really mean him all the time
right but in this
this whenever you're in conversation say
well ask him you don't mean jim johnson
exactly right in this case
that's up to him you don't mean jim
drama exactly okay
uh we have we think the same you and i
yeah
almost yeah it's close
there are differences i have a clip here
anything we need to know to set up this
clip yeah matthew had trouble setting up
his clip how about you
this was uh like
you thought you were safe from a quick
camera shot
no matter you're never safe here during
this the tape is going through the
machine
i only
i clearly only have myself to blame
let's take a look at this clip from
coffee and cigarettes
can you hear me what can you hear it's
very loud over here
you have you having trouble hearing me
maybe we should switch
yes yes thank you very much i like to
switch
ah good
good kinda i like the bedroom there
you go well
that goes on for untold
[Music]
90 minutes i'm told that
that that's pretty much 90 minutes of
the film is is you two switching seats
that was the part with the special
effects
it's incense around yes that's what i
heard anyway